In congestion collapse, an increase in traffic load
suddenly results in a decrease of useful work done.
As we can see here, up to a point, as we increase network load, there is an
increase in useful work done. At some point,
the network reaches saturation, at which point increasing the
load no longer results in useful work getting done.
But at some point, actually increasing the traffic load
can cause the amount of work done or the amount of traffic forwarded to actually
decrease. There are many possible causes. One possible
cause is the spurious re-transmissions of packets that
are still in flight. So when senders
don't receive acknowledgements for packets in a timely
fashion, they can spuriously re-transmit, thus resulting in
many copies of the same packets being outstanding
in the network at any one time.
Another cause of congestion collapse is simply undelivered
packets, where packets consume resources and are dropped
elsewhere in the network. The solution to spurious
re-transmissions is to have better timers and to
use TCP congestion control, which we'll talk about
next. The solution to undelivered packets is to
apply congestion control to all traffic. Congestion control
is the topic of the rest of this lesson.